meine damen und herren ich war mal
wieder unterwegs in den weiten des
internets ich hab mich auf der
videoplattform youtube rumgetrieben wo
influenza ihres mal meine absolute
lieblingsstadt jubeln mit der ich mich
am besten verstehe auf der kompletten
plattform ist babys beauty palace denn
ich bin irgendwann mal in echt treffen
dürfte würde ich ca so reagieren
[Musik]
nein wie bist du ja gib mir geld
ich liebe dich trotzdem aber das ist
jetzt komplett egal ich denke dieser
moment sind nie in meinem leben
vorkommen lassen wir das alles mal außen
vor ich habe wirklich überhaupt nichts
gegen die wie persönlich ich möchte sie
hier mit dem keinster weise angreifen
ich denke das ist jedem mittlerweile
bewusst das ganze hier ist alles auf
einer humorvollen basis aber auf jeden
fall babys beauty peres einen youtube
kanal mit 4,8 millionen abonnenten und
601 videos für mich jetzt hier einfach
mal auf ihren kanal draufklicken kommen
wir dementsprechend auf ihr
[Musik]
die liegt wie so eine leberwurst wir
sind jetzt auf jeden fall hier auf ihrem
youtube kanal angekommen und dann haben
wir die möglichkeit einfach mal auf
videos zu klicken und hier oben auf
sortieren nach hinzugefügt alte nach neu
zu machen dann sehen wir nämlich ihr
ältestes video ist fünf jahre alt haare
an der kopfhaut flechten ich denke die
meisten von euch können sich noch daran
erinnern dass ich vor eineinhalb monaten
als ich im winter urlaub war auf die
ersten videos von einigen youtube an
reagiert habe unter anderem auf erste
videos von mir von max von julien band
von paletten region unter anderem auch
von bibi und sie hat die kompletten
werbeeinnahmen für sich bestimmt von
meinem video weil sie 50 sekunden zu
sehen war das aber ein komplett anderes
thema das haben wir komplett abgehakt
ist ja alles schön und gut dass sie ist
jetzt auf schoko maske selber machen
wie sieht sie denn da aus aber auch
komplett egal meine damen und herren es
tut mir leid dass ich immer so ein
bisschen abdrifte weil ich meine es ist
wenn der lieblings
da kann ich einfach nicht anders ich
habe mich auf jeden fall gefragt mensch
okay das älteste video von ihr seitliche
flechtfrisur wir klicken noch mal drauf
drücken natürlich nach hause bevor ich
wieder irgendwas geklemmt wird oder so
also zweiter zwölfter 2012 und da denkt
man sich natürlich erstmal okay zweiter
zwölfter 2012 das ist jetzt fünf jahre
und zwei monate ich ja das ist schon
relativ lange zeit aber hatte babys
beauty palace eventuell vor dem kanal
babys beauty palace noch einen weiteren
kanal gehabt bei mir ist es nämlich so
ich habe zwar diesen kanal congo after
schrägstrich luca hier auf dem ein
erstes video auch irgendwie 56 jahre alt
ist allerdings hatte ich davor bereits
andere kanäle auf den ich davor schon
videos gemacht habe mich dann allerdings
irgendwie so gefunden habe und gedacht
habe komme ich machen neuen kanal und
machte alles clean und schön und meine
damen und herren investigativer
journalismus wird auf diesem kanal hier
ganz ganz groß geschrieben deswegen habe
ich mich auf die suche begeben ich bin
durch die weiten des internets ist rollt
auf einem kanal zu entdecken den wie vor
bibi hatte also ein kanal den es vor
babys beauty pelle schon gab juti
lauschte wie das logo ist ein fernseher
wurden kamen drin ist hand aufs herz
meine damen und herren der ganze kanal
sieht auf den ersten blick aus wie ein
werbekanal wir sehen hier beauty lounge
die wie von klippe bis zu 15 euro pro
video mit der clips er kippt kippen was
hier steht klipp und hier steht kickflip
und hier steht wieder klipfel haben die
ihr eigenes unternehmen in ihrer eigenen
werbung falsch geschrieben
naja also ist ja auch egal ob sie jetzt
gipfel bürger klipfel preis ich meine
zum us-markt im endeffekt niemanden auf
jeden fall war ich auf diesem kanal mal
unterwegs und das erste was man wirklich
sieht es anleitung hausmittel gegen
gelbe zähne um mit einem hausmittel
gegen gelbe zähne diese wieder weiß zu
bekommen
das ist komplett falsches deutsch an der
stelle lieber kanal beauty lounge tv
wenn man gelbe zähne hat würde ich eine
zahnbürste empfehlen das ist so ziemlich
der beste live-act es gibt jedes
hausmittel gegen gelbe ziehen sollte man
aber nicht als so verwenden bla bla bla
bla bla auf jeden fall ist dass ihr das
erste video was angezeigt wird und wenn
wir auf den kanal gehen ist natürlich
eine autoplay funktion vorhanden
das heißt ich klicke jetzt einfach mal
auf play und das hört man wenn man auf
den kanal geht in diesem video zeige ich
euch wie man gelbe zähne mit hausmitteln
bekämpfen kann
und das ist babys wird die welle sollte
der kanal entdeckt also wir haben nicht
ihren kanal entdeckt sondern wir haben
den kanal dem vbs youtube entdeckt und
ihr fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich hey
luca warum freust du dich da jetzt gegen
die so krass m das ist halt nicht so wie
wenn ein youtuber 1 2 kanal hat und das
ist komplett bekannt und publik sondern
dieser kanal hat erst 18 tausend
abonnenten wenn wir mal hier auf social
blades netz gehen sehen wir dass der
kanal durchschnittlich täglich irgendwie
minus 1 bis minus 4 die abos macht
dieser kanal
ist bei sas
bei niemandem auf dem schirm aber das
soll es ja gar nicht alles interessieren
wir machen das mal wieder zu klicken bei
beauty lounge die auf videos und klicken
auch sortieren nach alt nach neu und
schon mal das erste video nämlich
gesichtsmaske selber machen eine
anleitung und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video um in diesem video
möchte ich glaube wir sind uns alle
einig dass das nicht babys beauty palace
ist und daher schließen wir das video
mal und gucken uns wie kann ich harre
aufhellen / haare heller
ich wollte mal ein paar praktische
hausmittel zeigen die euch helfen könne
neuer haar etwas aufzuhellen
das
ist das wahr babys blieb alles so wie es
aussieht wird sich dieser kanal hier
wohl geteilt in den kommentaren steht
wird es beispielsweise backpulver macht
die haare kaputt alkohol macht jahre
kaputt menschen ohne worte als ob ich
zitrone auf meine haare machen gehe ich
habe es ausprobiert gleich punktgleich
nichts die tipps vom beauty lounge die
werden anscheinend harsch kritisiert in
den kommentaren das nächste video scream
selber machen eine anleitung das heißt
wichtig noch da mal eben drauf hallo und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video von mir ja das ist auch noch nicht
die bibel
ich bin ein junge
darf ich mir etwa nicht lidschatten
auftragen nachdem wir uns jetzt die ihr
erster hochgeladenen videos des kanals
beauty lounge die wie angeschaut haben
ist es nun an der zeit dass eine person
auftritt auf diesem kanal die für immer
alles verändern sollte und deutschlands
halten sie das aldi schon deutschlands
größte youtube werden sollte meine damen
und herren ich rede hier von niemand
geringerem als auge drücken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir kriegen jetzt auch auf dieses video
ja einfach mal drauf und sehen schon das
video wurde am 23 07 2012 hochladen also
viereinhalb monate bevor der kanal babys
beauty palace erstellt wurde meine damen
und herren ich klicke jetzt hier
gemeinsam mit euch einfach auf play in
diesem video zeige ich euch wie ihr eure
augen groß finden könnt dafür dahin will
bio die videos mit dem smartphone und
verdiene bis zu zehn euro pro video clip
bei youtube eine scheibe von abschneiden
alter ich fange mit dem eyeliner an ok
damit mache ich anja den strich denn
nach hinten etwas dekra wird okay
wie sieht das denn gerade aus ich habe
mir wirklich wieder so ein bisschen
angst dass content id automatisch das
video claim das war letztes mal nicht
wie das irgendwie manuell gemacht hat
oder so sondern das war ja irgendeine
funktion die sie anscheinend als große
youtube zur verfügung gestellt bekommen
von youtube deswegen will ich jetzt
nicht komplett auf die das ganze video
hier reagieren wir gehen einfach mal so
ein bisschen durchschauen dass man so
ein paar bildchen an hier macht sie sich
gerade die augen hier
guckt sie ein bisschen komisch dann
geht's hier weiter dass gegen pinsel
zeigt hier macht sie sich wieder die
augen wieder die augen wieder die augen
wieder die augen wieder die augen wieder
die augen mal schauen was jetzt hier am
ende sagt die letzten 80 kunden meine
damen und herren schauen uns jetzt
nochmal an
und so sieht das fertige wundervoll aber
wir gehen mal wieder zurück auf den
kanal meine damen und herren und zwar
sind wir wieder bei beauty lounge sowie
das nächste ist hausmittel bei
sonnenbrand mal schauen ob das die bi
diesmal kommentiert hat in diesem video
zeige ich euch wie man am besten
sonnenbrand mit hausmitteln bekämpfen
kann
da war sie ja wirklich da hat sie schon
früher gewusst ich werde demnächst in so
vielen ländern immer urlaub machen da
brauche ich ein hausmittel gegen
sonnenbrand
die bitte sei nicht böse er sei es nur
spaß ich bin auch selber auf dem urlaub
in balkonien in köln
hier liegt grad schnee so ein hausmittel
gegen schnee brand die erste möglichkeit
ist man nimmt kartoffelscheiben
also
die erste möglichkeit jede kartoffel
normalerweise wenn mir jemand dass ihr
zeigen würde und sagen würde hätten wir
haben ja irgendwie petersilie oder was
das ist dann haben wir hier noch eine
kartoffel gurke tomate zitrone natürlich
denken der macht schnitzel legt das in
essig dann dreht der dax und dann gibt's
dazu lägen die sonde salat und
kartoffeln aber sind hausmittel bei
sonnenbrand kartoffelscheiben
wurfscheiben und tomatenscheiben und
legt auf die verbrannten und geröteten
stellen
dann liege ich da so aus scheiße ist wie
sonnenbrand erstmal gurke tomate hier
eine kartoffelpresse die andere
möglichkeit ist manchmal diese kacke bis
zu zehn euro pro beauty video verdienen
mit deinem iphone oder android mit clip
flipper geben man nimmt zitronen oder
limettensaft das mit also schütteres auf
eindruck hast dann auch auf die
geröteten und verbrannten stellen und
etwas einwirken
aha
den habe ich sogar oben das wäre sogar
ein hausmittel was ich auch habe also
dass wir sind auf jeden fall die tipps
von der bbs youtube llc kann die
kommentare gucken bist du babys youtube
youtube erlitt du das hört man ja gar
nicht an alle wiener toren da draußen
und auch wie falls du das gesehen sollte
ist jetzt glaube ich schon zum dritten
oder vierten mal das hier ist wirklich
nicht böse gemeint ich will ihm mit
jetzt kein beef anzetteln oder so ich
habe nur diesen kanal gefunden und
dachte hey baby wollen würde dass der
kanal nicht mehr öffentlich ist dann wer
bestimmt schon offline aber daher hat
öffentlich ist kann ich darauf reagieren
und ich meine dass ich echt gemacht muss
ich wirklich mein lob aussprechen also
du bist viel selbstbewusster geworden
versprechen mich natürlich erstmal die
video ist viel viel selbstbewusster
geworden vor der kamera du hast deine
komplette statur verbessert als wenn ich
mir das angucken wir können jetzt war
draufklicken ich meine nummer
du bist du hast also das ist wirklich
nicht böse gemeint die wie du hast dich
echt gemacht das muss ich dir wirklich
lassen
wir klingen jetzt trotzdem hier mal ganz
oft leben ich find's cool dass sie alles
rosa abgestimmt hat sogar die
anmerkungen hier hier gibt es auf jeden
fall einige zahlreiche videos von der
baby und das letzte video was sie glaube
ich mehr oder weniger hochgeladen hat
ist lange haare zusammenstecken das
heißt es
relativ krass weil das ist ja zwei
wochen bevor sie ihren eigenen kanal
dann aufgemacht hat also meine damen und
herren abschließend festhalten die bi
hat ihre youtube karriere nicht mit dem
kanal babys kritiker des gestartet
sondern schon einige monate vorher mit
dem kanal beauty lounge die wie der von
clip flip irgendwie zusammenarbeit damit
war ich habe mir gedacht ich reagiere
einfach mal auf diesen kanal und zeigt
euch das wirklich nicht jeder mensch
perfekt ist und nicht jeder mensch
perfekte videos macht auch bibi hat
keine andere meine damen und herren das
heißt wenn ihr einen traum habt meine
damen und herren
lasst euch nicht davon unterkriegen dass
andere leute das eventuell schon besser
können oder keine ahnung was freunde
glaubt dann euren traum